gute Nachrichten heute auch vom
Gesundheitsminister die Corona
sommerwelle Klinge ab robuster Rückgang
der Infektionszahlen geringe
Sterblichkeit der Rückgang ist echt
betonte Lauterbach sogar extra nochmal
wäre aber natürlich nicht Lauterbach
wenn ich gleich eine Warnung hinterher
käme die die Freude sofort wieder
einkassiert dass alles sei kein Grund zu
Entwarnung im Herbst wird die Zahlen ja
wieder steigen und dann stellte er die
neuen Maßnahmen vor die er plant unter
anderem bei Veränderung von
impfzertifikaten und dann hielt er um
das zu demonstrieren in der
Pressekonferenz von den Journalisten
sein Handy mit seinem eigenen
impfzertifikat hoch das war schon laut
Anleitungen in der App ausdrückliche
nicht ratsam und da klicken natürlich
die Kameras und es wurden Fotos gemacht
und mein Kollege Benedikt Weimer ist bei
mir im Studio denn diese Fotos haben
durchaus folgen
ja das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant
denn man kann dieses impfzertifikat ja
scannen wenn man einfach die normale
corona-warn-app hat und das Ergebnis ist
spannend denn es kommt raus dass da nur
drei Impfungen hinterlegt sind also es
scheint als habe Karl Lauterbach doch
keine vierte Impfung über seinen
Impfstatus also gelogen wir haben
natürlich dazu das
Gesundheitsministerium angefragt und das
hat gesagt nein es geht alles mit
rechten Dingen zu Karl Lauterbach ist
viermal geimpft hat aber vergessen die
vierte Impfung anzugeben
jetzt sieht man auch dass da steht als
Impfung bei Impfstoff biontech er hat ja
immer gesagt dass er mit Astra Zenica
geimpft worden ist das kann natürlich
sein dass dann die dritte Impfung die
Auffrischungsimpfung diese
booster-impfung dieser damals nicht mehr
mit astrazenika gemacht worden genauso
wird das sein Karl Lauterbach hat im
Februar 2021 gesagt ist wichtig wir
sollten uns alle damit impfen lassen
sich später tatsächlich damit impfen
lassen nach eigener Aussage und die
booster-impfung das wird bionte gewesen
sein der entscheidende Punkt aber ist
jetzt natürlich auch dass das Wasser auf
die Mühlen all jener Impfgegner ist die
sagen meine Daten sind da nicht sicher
das ist alles viel zu gefährlich ja das
ist dazu tatsächlich ein wenig brisant
denn die Experten empfehlen auch dass
man sein impfzertifikat öffentlich nicht
zeigt dass man es keinen anderen Leuten
zuschickt per Screenshot oder in den
sozialen Medien verbreitet und genau das
macht Karl Lauterbach ja hier indem er
vor dutzenden Journalisten in der
breiten Öffentlichkeit sein
impfzertifikat zeigt das heißt jeder der
will kann theoretisch das Zertifikat
scannen und beim nächsten Kneipenbesuch
mit Karl Lauterbach unter Kar Lauterbach
firmieren und das Vorzeigen auch wenn er
persönlich gar nicht geimpft ist also
das hätte er besser bleiben gelassen ja
da wollte er also was demonstrieren
hätte er auf diese Art und Weise nicht
machen sollen eine Karl Lauterbach danke
Benedikt für die Erklärung und wir
schauen dann jetzt mal auf die Maßnahmen
meine Damen und Herren die er
vorgestellt hat auf das was uns dann im
Herbst womöglich wieder droht
pünktlich um 10 erscheint Professor Dr
Karl Lauterbach zur Pressekonferenz
seine Botschaft nach der coronawelle ist
vor der coronawelle das im Herbst wenn
wieder mehr Aufenthalt in Innenräumen
stattfindet und auch die Schule wieder
begonnen hat dass wir dann wieder stark
steigende Fahrzeugen erwarten müssen
dass es auch eine der Gründe deshalb
habe ich Ihnen gleich das
Infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal etwas
näher erläutern werde und das hat es in
sich ab dem 1 Oktober dürfen die
Bundesländer wieder die maskenpflicht
einführen und das völlig Inzidenz
unabhängig heißt maskenpflicht im
Nahverkehr in öffentlich zugänglichen
Innenräumen sogar in der Schule ab der
fünften Klasse in der Bahn und im
Flugzeug will der Bund sogar die
ffp2-maskenpflicht vorschreiben in
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
soll eine masken- und testpflicht
greifen bei einer noch dramatischeren
corona-situation dürfen die Länder auch
wieder Personen Obergrenzen auf
Veranstaltungen einführen damit nicht
genug entsch man sich ein Bundesland für
die maskenpflicht gilt diese
grundsätzlich auch in der Gastroszene
wenn sie es aber machen dann müssen sie
eine Ausnahme vorsehen für die
Innenräume wo das Masken tragen ersetzt
werden kann heißt geimpfte getestete
oder genesene können die Maske erst
einmal in der Tasche lassen für geimpfte
und Genesende gilt das jedoch nur für
drei Monate das ist die Dauer wo wir
glauben dass die neuen Impfungen auch
vor Ansteckung schützen also nicht nur
vor schwerem Verlauf sondern auch für
Ansteckung lange gilt die Maske als
Zeichen der Solidarität in der
corona-pandemie damit schützt man sich
aber vor allem auch andere im dritten
corona-herbst müssen wir die Maske nun
einzig zum eigenen Schutz vor einer
Infektion tragen zur Kontrolle dessen
setzt der Gesundheitsminister auf die
Konsequenz der Restaurantbesitzer
notfalls per Stichprobe sollen sie ihre
Gäste beim Essen stören um den Nachweis
zu prüfen wie das genau ablaufen soll
weiß Professor Lauterbach auch schon
greift sogar selbst zum Smartphone da
kann man denn mal wirklich Stichproben
machen wir kann man sagen können Sie mir
noch gerade noch mal ihren Test zeigen
vereinfacht soll die Kontrolle durch die
neu designte corona-warn-app bewerben
anstatt blau gibt es dann grün für 3G
zeigt die App wieder blau heißt es Maske
wieder auf wer ohne Maske leben will
müsste sich nach dieser Regel also alle
drei Monate impfen lassen doch daran
glaubt selbst Lauterbach nicht und
twittert glauben Sie im Ernst dass
Menschen sich alle drei Monate impfen
lassen um ohne Maske in ein Restaurant
gehen zu können in der
Bundespressekonferenz stellt er das auch
noch mal klar das wird erstens kein Arzt
wollen wird wahrscheinlich auch kein
Arzt tun soll ich vorgesehen ständig ist
impfen auf keinen Fall aber Nachteile
gibt es trotzdem darum jetzt noch mal
richtig maskenfrei durchat ab Oktober
geht's wieder los
tja macht das alles Sinn das fragen wir
den Epidemiologen und Virologen Klaus
Stör der auch Mitglied des expertenrates
der Bundesregierung ist und Darsteller
machen diese Maßnahmen alle Sinn
ja ich möchte erstmal sagen ich bin im
Sachverständigenausschuss nicht im
Expertenrat aber die Maßnahmen machen so
in der Grenze und auch in der Anlehnung
an Wissenschaft nicht komplett sind das
ist ein langes Spektrum das fängt an mit
den drei Monaten da gibt's ja keine
Daten die das auch belegen dass man in
der Zeit wirklich dann weniger
ansteckungsfähig ist man darf auch nicht
vergessen man setzt hier die
Jugendlichen eigentlich unter Druck und
letztendlich entweder machen Sie das was
die STIKO empfiehlt also nur die über
70-Jährigen oder dann man oder die
machen das was im Gesundheit im
Infektionsschutzgesetz dann steht also
irgendwo wird man dann anerkennen damit
also fachlich macht das nicht so viel
Sinn aber das Schlimme ist dass die
gesamte Diskussion über diese drei
Monate eigentlich ablenkt von der
Unsinnigkeit das Masken Tragens in den
Restaurants da hat man vielleicht ein
Prozent der Zeit die Maske auf nämlich
wenn man zum Tisch geht oder vielleicht
zur Toilette und die ganze restliche
Zeit hat man die nicht also die
Wirksamkeit ist hier sehr beschränkt und
es lenkt auch ab von dem Masken tragen
in der Schule von dem ansatzlosen Test
in der Schule dass nun wirklich völlig
daneben ist sowohl in der Zeit also von
den fachlichen vom fachlichen
Hintergrund sie sind mit dem
Sachverständigenrat beraten also auch
die Regierung was ist denn ihr Rat dann
mein Rat würde sein dass jemand die
Ecken und Kanten abschleift die drei
Monate als Vorzug dann dass man die
Maske nicht tragen muss im Restaurant
und die müssen kassiert werden wenn man
sollte sich genau überlegen ob es sinn
ergibt weil tatsächlich die
maskenpflicht wieder in den Schulen
einzuführen der Bundesausschuss für die
Kinder und Jugendlichen die Pädiater
Kinder und Jugendlichen die sprechen
nicht eindeutig dagegen das Ansatz
sollte testen muss man komplett
überdenken und man darf auch nicht eins
vergessen letztendlich hat man gar keine
Parameter die Länder werden jetzt also
nach Gusto entscheiden oder nach Risiko
Potenzial wie sie sich fühlen ob welche
Maßnahmen bei welchem Grenzwerten
umgesetzt werden also da fliegenteppich
ist vorgeschrieben er hat der Bund
vergessen
vorab auch mit den Ländern zu
konsultieren vielleicht ein Stufenplan
vorzustellen also man hat ja was schnell
zusammengestrickt was fachlich nicht
ganz sauber ist an einigen Ecken
grundsätzlich muss natürlich sagen man
braucht das für ein Herbst es sind
wesentlich notwendig es wird ein
heftiger Winter werden weil nicht nur
Corona sondern andere Atemwegserkrankung
auch trotzdem aber mit dem was sie
gegenwärtig auf dem Tisch liegt kann man
sicherlich nicht effizient und nicht der
epidemiologischen Lage entsprechend auch
bekämpfen Klaus vielen Dank für ihre
Einordnung ich bedanke mich
[Musik]